hello everyone and welcome to the final
match end of the final game of the fish
random World Championship 2022 it is
Hikaru Nakamura versus Yani polishi and
this is the Armageddon game which means
that whoever plays the white pieces must
win otherwise
um uh if it's a draw or black wins then
black wins the title first four games uh
were very hard fought Hikaru started by
winning game one then game two ended in
Android then Jan uh I retaliated in game
three and the game 4 also ended in a
draw I didn't want to probably decided
uh you know it's for the game everything
is it stands they don't want to uh you
know it's like basically it's like
throwing a dice but then again the
alternative is Armageddon which is okay
you get the white pieces you have to win
it's it's up to you so Hikaru gets white
in Armageddon and now let's see the game
this is the position and it's the weird
one that everyone hates uh the uh uh
King in between the two towers it's like
the uh I haven't really watched Lord the
Rings a a while ago but it's there is
something with the two towers in there
but and there's also something with the
King like one of the titles is with the
King but so I thought that was funny uh
but okay uh uh let's see the game Hikaru
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to B3 and here even though the
openings don't really have names here we
will have a super symmetrical variation
Pawn to B3 with Pawn to B6 both of them
uh developed their Bishops or rather uh
open up their Bishops with e for E5 and
now Pawn to G3 we have Pawn to G6 Hikaru
plays F4 and now Pawn to F5 and now F
captures an E4 on E5 uh Bishop captures
an E5 now attacking the bishop on uh on
A1 but now e captures an F1 look at this
opening up this diagonal as well and now
the bishop on each one is hanging but
also the bishop on E5 is hanging so how
do you play this uh Bishop captures an
A1 and now Bishop of captures on E5 we
have G captures and F5 and now Bishop
them back to C3 offering a trade of
Queens Bishop back to C6 and now Knight
the E3 we have Queen to H5 going after
the H2 pawn and uh Queen to F2 Hikaru
just nicely defends it we have knighted
the H6 Bayan and now we have Knight the
E2 preparing Knight Steve F4 to go after
the queen Knight to the E6 now taking
care of the F4 square and now Rook the
F1 putting pressure on the F5 Pawn but
not really just King to B7 by Hikaru
artificially castling and um if you
capture just rook f8 and
uh sorry King to B7 uh and now if you
capture on F5 then just Rook to f8 and
you can resign there's uh no way to grab
the pawn so just spawn the D4 by Hikaru
and not Knight the G4 attacking the
queen uh in the night and basically
asking Hikaru do you want a capture on
G4 or do you want to move the queen but
Hikaru plays something very interesting
he plays Queen to F5 and he completely
blunders the game away luckily Jan does
not spot it and it's not very easy to
spot
uh point is you have to play a move that
is Queen to H6 and it seems like okay
what's so hard to spot about this we're
just attacking the Knight twice
obviously we win the game because we win
the piece well it's not as clear because
you have to see a move uh ahead and I
guess hikar just trusted Jan because you
have to see that after Bishop D2 and the
Knight captures on E3 there's this very
nice Queen to D3 moon now preparing to
win back the piece and now you have to
find or sorry rather not Queen T4 Queen
to D3 uh preparing to win back the piece
and now of course this very nice Queen
to H3 and The Rook on F1 is unguarded
that's the the problem and this is what
you have to see and now okay if you
capture the Knight then a young captures
the rook and if you save The Rook lets
you play rookie one then just Knight
back to D5 you're up a piece and of
course completely winning so here we
have a case of maybe yeah I wouldn't
call it double blindness maybe just um
Hikaru trusting yarn a bit too much so
here uh or rather young thrusting heat
car too much so here Queen captures an
F5 he just trades Queens Knight captures
on F5 and now Knight captures on H2
attacking The Rook here Rook the E1 and
now Rook the f8 putting pressure on the
F5 Knight so Knight back to E3 and now
Bishop to E4 yeah an excellent diagonal
for this light Square Bishop we have
Pawn to D5 and now Knights the G5 we
have Knight to F4 and now Rook B
at the E8 developing both of the Rooks
and now King to B2 and Nakamura also
artificially castles with Bishop the F3
and now we have Pawn to D6 a very
resourceful move by yeah Hikaru either I
think okay uh you can destroy your Pawn
structure uh but if you play something
like C characters and D6 then there's
this very tricky Knight to F5 and what
is really happening here seems like
you're giving up a knight but then the
Rook hangs but if you play Rook captures
a new one first uh then Knight captures
and D6 comes with check and after King
to C6 look at this Rook capture Sunny
one and now you might think okay but
there's King captures on D6 nope just
Bishop the B for check and then the rook
and f8 uh hangs as well so it's not um
that clear how to play this it's a very
nice find but he covered the spawn to D6
move so Jan just blocks it pawn to C6
maybe Pawn to C5 was better in some
lines as it does free up the C6 Square
for the light Square Bishop but I mean
who's the uh who's the I predicted this
in an Armageddon game so here Knight the
C4 uh grabbing some very important
squares Knight the E4 uh now putting
pressure on the bishop here and also if
the Knight moves maybe you can get rid
of the spawn and now Knight the E5 look
at this um uh wonderful wonderful move
what is the idea behind this well if
Knight captures on uh uh on D6 you're
gonna capture on D7 and now you've
pretty much ruined Black's um black
spawn structure here the The Rook here
is hanging so you have to trace some
Little Rock captures Rook captures and
the game continues uh the material is
equal white maybe a little bit better
but again very hard to say in the actual
game after Knight the E5 Knight captures
and C3 was played and now King captures
on C3 and the bishop to G4 uh defending
the pawn here on D7 we have rooked the
E3 and now Pawn to H5 the bishop now
nicely defended maybe the Knight can get
back into the game Rook beat the E1 and
with this Rook vte1 move Hikaru
basically leaves Yan without a move it's
it's incredibly difficult to find a good
move here to give you an example if you
play a weird move let's say you play
Pawn to F5 then just Knight captures on
G4 and you can resign here you just lost
a piece The Rook on d8 is hanging an E8
and if you trade then just knight uh
recapture so whatever you you're down a
piece so that's the the threat behind
this very nice Rook BTE one move uh and
if you play something like Bishop to F5
which is the only reasonable idea as you
don't want to allow Knight captures on
G4 then you allow the H5 Pawn to be
captured and okay then you can maybe go
after this spawn then we can see
something like Knight the G7 Rook
captures on D6 and now Rook 3 to E2 uh
but then this Knight now is is trapped
and there's no good way to to save it
you can't really go here the Knight
covers this if you go to G4 then just
Knight captures bishop and then you you
pick up the night Soul white will always
be much better here so instead after
Rook beat the E1 Ian does pretty much
the only thing left and that is a rook
captures any five and the engine agrees
within this is the absolute top move
recommended by the engine uh Rook
captures on E5 and now Knights the F3
seemingly winning back the material but
not really Rook to E8 by Hikaru now
saying okay you capture anyone I'm gonna
capture an f8 so Rook to F6 now goes
after the D6 pawn and now Rook to H1 so
Jan will not be winning back his
exchange Rook captures on D6 and now uh
you can't capture right away if you
can't right away then Rook H6 and again
uh you you have problems here so instead
after Rook cat percent D6 Rook the G8 by
Hikaru and now Rook the D2 Yan abandons
the defense of the of the H5 Pawn
there's really no good way to do it uh
and he goes after the ct1 he wants to
play Bishop F5 and go after it so here
we have Knight captures on H5 and now
Bishop to F5 going after the C2 pawn and
it seems like Jan is about to strike
back but just Rook the C1 but he current
there's no good way to threaten uh that
pawn it seems like you could play
something like let's say Knight D1 but
of course uh then you you leave The Rook
undefended then also it's a it's a weird
move to play so here Rook the H2 going
after the Knight and not Knight back to
G7 going after the bishop Bishop to E4
now and now comes a move that is not
easy to spot uh because it's one of
those moves that you never think of but
Hikaru spots it and that is Knights the
E8 point is that uh let's say you play
something like G4 you want to start
pushing your Pawn then C5 is played
something that we mentioned when C6 was
played and now once this bishop comes to
C6 it's not gonna be easy for example
now you play Knight the E8 Bishop the C6
and everything is fine uh you you might
be even able to hold this position but
after Bishop to E4 Hikaru finds the
immediate Knight to the E8 and now the
threat of knights the D6 Fork forking
the king ended the bishop here is a
great one so here Rook the H6 you
prevent the knight from coming to D6 but
now Rook to f8 we have Pawn to D5 but
now Rook the F6 offering a rook trade
and he wants to go into
uh even more trades we have broke back
to H3 and now Knight to D6 with check
King to C7 and now Knight captures an E4
D captures and Rook to G6 now defending
his past g-pawn and yes both players
have four pawns but Hikaru is still up
the exchange Rook the H2 and now we have
Rook the E6 again are going after the E4
Pawn we have rooked the E2 defending the
pawn and now Rook the H1 we have pawned
the B5 you have to create some breeding
room for the king otherwise you might
just get checkmated uh so Ponte A3 and
now Rook the E3 with check and now King
the B2 this is an absolute must if you
go up the board sometimes you see
players do this um uh you know it looks
like a very active idea maybe you can
play something like this but then just
something like King the B6 and it's
actually your king uh that got that
might get checkmated something like
Knights the D4 capture C2 Checkmate and
you know stuff like that so after Rook
they three check of course Hikaru goes
to safety King to B2 and now we have
Knight to D4 preparing to put pressure
on that C2 Pawn but just Rook the H7
check King to B6 and now Rook e to E7
and now with with some ideas of maybe B4
and Rook to B7 Checkmate so here King
the C5 right away and now Rook the D7
Hikaru sets uh sets up a a deadly
maneuver Knight to F3 by Yan and now
it's actually a forced Checkmate in five
by Hikaru so feel free to pause the
video and win the entire official random
world championship for Hikaru while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding any
movie in the position because any move
is really a winning one but for those of
you who actually founded the mate in 5
like Hikaru did then congratulations you
are also a true master of puzzle Rush uh
uh so here you go uh and that of course
is Pawn to B4 check and now I know you
guys think I only chose this as a pause
the video moment because it's Pawn to B4
check but no it's really I mean it is it
just that it's always the winning move
even if even in fish are random like
it's not it's not like it's a ma it's
something that only uh relates to normal
chess you can see that even in visual
random B4 is just
overpowering uh so here King the C4 was
played and now uh we have Rook the H5
the other move you had to find and after
Rook to H5 it was in this position
animal 48 that uh Yani Pony resigned the
game and Hikaru not come Hikaru Nakamura
becomes the world's official random
Champion so big big congratulations to
Hikaru he crushed everyone I was uh
quite quite an event for him he just
completely obliterated of the Satur of
in the semi-finals like 3-0 not you're
not even allowing game four to happen uh
and then uh playing very nicely against
Dion here in the finals he started off
with a win but then Jan uh came back and
then he had to go into Armageddon and
yeah okay if you go up the board King B6
I forgot to mention this is also
Checkmate it's a very very
straightforward one just Rook the B7
Checkmate now and uh after a B4 check
King to C4 and Rook to H5 the move that
Hikaru found there is no stopping Rook
the C5 Checkmate you're gonna have to
give up uh a few pieces for for no good
reason and that's just it I mean
you could you could play Silly moves to
make the game go on a little bit longer
but basically Rook the C5 will be
Checkmate uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh I've been
pretty pretty busy today I've only
returned home so if you have any of the
games that you clean car are worth
showing or some of them are your own
favorites from as other games have been
played today aside from the uh Hikaru
Yan match up so do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over them uh so
yeah that's the game once again hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Nathan Halsey Jacoby more chess 9601
Carla morobo and the Martin York paparik
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day